- [Narrator] This
program is a presentation
of University of California Television.
Your support makes UCTV's
programing possible.
Contribute online at www.uctv.tv/support.
Check out our YouTube original channel,
UCTV Prime at YouTube.com/uctvprime.
Subscribe today to get
new programs every week.
(upbeat music)
- Welcome to a Conversation with History.
I'm Harry Kreisler
of the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is Samuel Scheffler
who is university professor
and professor of philosophy
and law at New York University.
He is the 2012 Tanner Lecturer
at the University of
California at Berkeley.
Sam, welcome back to Berkeley.
- Thank you very much.
I spent many happy years here,
and it's wonderful to be back.
- What can philosophy
contribute to public discourse?
I know that in your work
you focus on public issues.
What contribution do you
think philosophy makes
in that regard?
- It's always a very hard question
to answer about philosophy,
what kind of contribution it makes.
And I find that it generally works best
if you don't worry too much about it.
Philosophy to me is in part
sort of a way of wondering
about the world, the way of
being curious about the world.
And issues of public concern,
which have interested me,
though they've not been
my exclusive interests,
raise questions that
are deep and fascinating
and elicit sort of natural
philosophical curiosity.
And so when philosophers
turn their attention
to issues of public concern,
they contribute something,
a way of reflecting
to public discourse.
And there's no telling what
effects it will have or when,
and I think that the demand
that philosophy delivers
some specifiable results in the short term
is probably misplaced and unrealistic.
I like to think that it enriches
the public conversation,
but its effects are
gonna be unpredictable.
- And part of what this is about
is really clarifying the issues,
sort of mapping the terrain
to help people think?
- That's right.
Philosophers are sensitive
to conceptual distinctions,
to structures of argument as a matter
of sort of professional disposition.
These are sorts of things that we
worry about and are attuned to.
And I think in the modern age
now more than ever with sound bites
and media, food fights and a level
of public discourse that
is often not very edifying
it's especially useful to have someone
or some group of people
who wanna take the time
to contribute conceptual clarification
and demand some rigger
in the way arguments
are presented and so on,
though that's, of course,
not all that philosophers do.
- And central to this is
really about framing issues.
Let's take a problem and look at it
and see what the dimensions
of a problem are.
- That's right.
Often public issues in
particular someone will,
a politician or some media figure
will frame an issue for
purposes of public debate
in a certain way.
And a lot is driven by the
way it's initially framed.
And if the way it's initially framed
is not especially helpful or illuminating
or it's possibly even
misleading in certain respects
that can exert an unfortunate influence
on the way the subsequent
conversation goes.
- And what are the difficulties
of this process of framing?
If you have an issue
that is controversial,
what is the process like in laying out
the discourse in a way that reflects
the kinda insights of philosophy?
- Well, I think that a central
fact to be reckoned with
both in philosophy and in public life
is that the issues are
often extremely complicated.
Philosophers, in their
professional conversations
with one another, have
the luxury of taking
that complexity seriously.
And so philosophical
debates amongst philosophers
often strike outsiders
as being extremely dense
and complicated and so on
and inaccessible often.
When it comes to issues
of public concern, though,
there's in a way the opposite problem;
that is, the issues are just as complex,
what to do about problems
of climate change
or about the economic problems, so on.
The issues are extremely complicated,
but our public culture
demands simple formulations.
And politicians or other
people who have a stake
in some policy orientation will often rush
to frame the issue in
a way that they think
will be to their advantage.
Inevitably, they both
oversimplify the issues
and often conceal the
interests that lie behind
that particular way of
oversimplifying the issues.
So occasionally it can be useful for
I don't wanna oversell
the virtues of philosophy.
Occasionally it can be useful
to have someone come along,
it doesn't have to be a philosopher.
It could be any thoughtful person really.
And simply call attention to the fact
that the issues are being oversimplified,
to the ways they are being oversimplified,
and to try to persuade
people to see things
in a slightly different way.
- I like to ask my guests
what skills they think are involved
in the work that they do.
So what is ideal training for somebody
who wants to do philosophy
and has to develop
a set of skills and what are those skills?
- Well, some of the skills are
fairly readily identifiable.
Philosophy is a discipline that
demands a certain competence
in argument, in sensitivity
to structures of reasoning,
in understanding what
counts as a reasoning
and what counts as a valid
argument and what doesn't.
So an ability to engage in
critical thought more generally
and analytic thought is certainly
central to philosophical
training in all its forms.
There's also philosophy is
a subject with a history,
a very long history.
And many of its problems have histories.
And it's important for
people who want to come
to understand philosophy
or to study it deeply
to learn something of its history.
Questions can be framed for
the first time in the presence
but often they're
illuminated by understanding
the ways they've emerged and
the traditions of thought
that have grown up around them over time.
So that's another important dimension
of philosophical thought.
There's also a role,
though it's somewhat less
frequently commented upon,
for the imagination in philosophy.
Sometimes being a good philosopher
requires seeing things in different ways.
And it's not just a matter
of analyzing an argument
or finding, detecting a
fallacy or remembering
what some great philosopher said
and thinking about what he
or she might have meant.
But it's a matter of
inviting people to see things
in a different way,
and that requires certain
kinds of imaginative skills,
which are less easily taught.
- So in philosophy is creativity,
are there some features of
creativity in philosophy
that are distinctive or
is it the general problem
of creativity in all fields?
- Well, it's a certain kind of creativity.
It's not the kind of creativity
that a painter displays or a musician.
But it certainly is creativity.
And it's very difficult
to teach creativity.
So some of the problems
or questions that arise
about the creative process certainly apply
to the best work in philosophy,
the most original work,
which often involves
insight and imagination,
creating formulations
and ideas in ways of seeing things
that haven't occurred to others before.
- What about a temperament?
Are there qualities to the temperament
of a philosopher that are very important?
- Philosophers have as much variation
with respect to their temperaments
as any other group of people.
There are some who are cool and reflective
and there are some who are sort of
much more impetuous and intuitive.
I think all philosophers have some respect
for the complexity of the issues
that they're dealing with.
And if there's a common temperament really
it's a temperament, it's the
trait of being fascinated by
and responsive to the complexity
of philosophical issues.
And a willingness to tolerate the fact
that philosophical questions
don't get answered decisively
on the whole, the deepest questions don't,
in the way that a question in the natural
or social sciences might do.
- So it sounds like there can
be a great deal of frustration
in the process of unraveling
philosophical puzzles?
- Absolutely.
And certainly philosophy
is not a field for people
who want quick answers and
to make quick progress.
Philosophers are still
arguing about things
that the Greeks were arguing
about thousands of years ago.
- Talk a little about what
leads a philosopher like you
to particular problems.
Is it your education,
your background, or what
that leads you to focus on some subset
of problems in philosophy?
- Well, that's an
interesting question, Harry.
In a way, this is one
of the hardest things
that one has to learn as one goes on
and becomes an academic
probably in any field,
but certainly in philosophy.
When you first encounter
a subject like philosophy
as a student at the university typically
your teachers tell you
what the questions are.
They give you assignments.
They tell you paper topics
or set you exam questions.
And so you don't have to worry about
what the questions or topics
are or what's interesting.
Somebody tells you what's interesting.
And then one day you get a
PhD and you're turned loose
on the world as a professional philosopher
if you're fortunate
enough to find employment.
And then suddenly there's
nobody telling you
what the questions are anymore.
You have to decide for
yourself what's interesting
and what's worth thinking about.
Sometimes the ongoing discourse
among philosophers itself
will simply generate
questions that naturally exert
a fascination for you, given the things
you've been interested as a student,
been interested as a student and so on.
So there's a kind of
momentum that develops.
One thing leads to another and so on.
But increasingly as you go on,
it's always a question,
what the next new topic
is going to be for you.
You get tired of thinking about exactly
the same things all the time.
And it's not a field like science
in which the field itself
or at least this is a
non-scientist's perspective,
the field itself exerts
sufficient momentum
that's pretty clear to
people what the next
set of issues might be in a given field
that you want to explore.
Philosophers, again, there's an element
of serendipity to it.
Sometimes something
just pops into your head
as something that seems
curious or interesting
or fascinating and worth pursuing.
And philosophers then have the luxury
of being able to follow their
ideas wherever they may lead.
So it's a mix, I think,
of professional agendas
that exert their own weight
and an element of
imaginative and serendipitous
circumstance that leads one to
select a particular question.
And then sometimes there are
issues in the wider culture
that simply suggest questions
that haven't loomed as salient before
and philosophers or some
philosophers will take those up.
- One of the topics that you have focused
on and that emerges in some
of the pieces that I read
your Tanner lectures and some
of the essays in your book
Equality and Tradition
is the notion of valuing.
Just out of curiosity,
how does that example
fit in to what you describe
as to how you wound up-
how did you wind up focusing
on that particular problem?
- Well, over the years it seemed to me
that questions about the nature of value,
but also questions about
what it is for a person
to value something kept cropping up
as I was thinking about other things.
I was thinking, for example, about issues
to do with the kinds of obligations
that are generated by participation
in a personal relationship.
On the one hand, most of us think that we
should treat all people decently
and that moral norms apply to
our treatment of people in general,
strangers especially, was
well as people we know.
But on the other hand,
we feel we have special responsibilities
to close family members,
friends, and so on.
And so there's a kind of a tension
between the norms that tell
us how to treat all people
and the norms that tell us we have special
things we should do for
people we're close to.
And this tension manifests
itself in our personal lives
and it also manifests itself politically.
Tension between more
universalist and cosmopolitan
strands and political
thought on the one hand,
and then more identity
based and community based
and nation based ways of
thinking on the other hand.
And the more I thought about
those sorts of questions,
which I did for a number of years,
the more I was led to ask
to think that a lot of
what seems to be the source
of our special responsibilities
toward family members
and friends and so on
seem to have to do with
the kind of significance
those relationships had for us
and the ways in which we valued then
and what it meant to value
those personal relationships.
So I began to wonder, and
that's just one example,
but several different problems led me
in a similar sort of way to wonder a bit
about what exactly it
was to value something.
I think in our culture now
there's a certain amount
of skepticism about valuing.
People are skeptical about values.
They're suspicious of values.
People are more comfortable talking
about just desires and wants and so on.
It's a discourse that our culture
seems more comfortable with.
But I think valuing is very
central human attitude.
I think we would be very different
and unrecognizable creatures
if we didn't value things
in addition to just wanting things.
- In the essay that I read,
you said about clarifying
the importance of this
by identifying the features
of what one values.
Talk a little about that.
Because you're telling us that
there are several features
and in understanding them
you can really understand
better this problem of valuing.
- Yeah.
It's hard to clarify
the notion of valuing.
And there's a tendency,
one natural thought is to
think that to value something
is just to want it a lot,
to have a very strong desire for it
or to have a desire of
a certain kind for it.
But that didn't seem to me quite right.
Sometimes we strongly desire something
that we don't especially value.
Another thought is that,
well, maybe valuing something
is just thinking it's a valuable thing.
So if you think like some
painting is very valuable,
maybe that means you value it.
But that didn't seem quite right either
because it seemed possible to recognize
that something is valuable
without, in another sense,
valuing it yourself.
So I was, in the end, led to the idea
that valuing is actually a kind
of complex syndrome of attitudes.
It partly involves the belief
that whatever it is you value is valuable.
But it also partly involves
being somehow emotionally
invested in the thing,
such that if something bad
happens to it you're upset
or if it flourishes you
are pleased and so on.
The emotions in question will vary,
depending on what it is that you value,
whether it's an institution
or a relationship
with a particular person
or an artifact and so on.
Also the things we value generate reasons
for us to act in certain ways.
If I claim to value, say,
my friendship with you
but I'm never led to do
anything on that basis,
if you call me up and say
you need help with something,
I said, well, sorry, not interested,
and if I keep doing that over time
you would begin to think
that I wasn't being honest
or very self-aware if I claim
to value the friendship.
If you value something,
then it gives you reasons
to act in a certain way.
So I take valuing to be a
complex set of attitudes
involving beliefs about the
items, that it's valuable
or worthy or worthwhile.
Dispositions to feel certain emotions
depending on how things
go with the valued item,
and also a tendency to see the valued item
as a source of reasons for
me to act in a certain way.
- And this syndrome,
these features, together really clarify,
as you just said, everything
from your relations
to your colleagues to
your family, to a cause
that you might find very important.
And I guess that in a modern society
the complexity of what we value
really multiplies.
- Yes, absolutely.
And the first step toward
making some progress
in this area is to recognize
that we do value things.
The language of economics and
the language of the market
and the language of
marketing sometimes lead us
to believe that everything's
just another want
to which you can attach a price tag.
And it's important to remember
and to recover our sense
that certain things in life
are not things we just want,
they're things that matter to us,
that are important to us,
that we value or care deeply about.
And understanding that we
have a stake in some things
as opposed to others.
And once you have that insight,
then you begin to see that
our values are actually
quite complicated and they
pull us in different directions
and that they need to be understood.
- As I thought about your essay on this
and what you're saying
in some of the essays
we'll discuss in a minute,
I was struck by really
one of the characteristics
of political conflict
today is there's so much
disagreement about what
different groups value.
In other words, they value
things very strongly,
but as a political society
we're having difficulty
reconciling the different
groups to each other
with regard to what they value.
- Absolutely.
For a liberal society in particular
in a way the central
contemporary predicament
is the fact that such societies
are always pluralistic
with respect to values.
People differ with respect
to their evaluative ideas
and commitments, their
moral, their philosophical,
their religious outlooks and values.
And that kind of disagreement
is not gonna go away
in a free society.
The only way it can go
away or seem to go away
is through the autocratic
use of state power.
John Rawls, great late 20th
Century political philosopher,
said that what he called the
fact of reasonable pluralism
was the fundamental fact
that liberal thinkers
had to come to terms
with in thinking about
how social institutions
should be structured.
And it's obvious just from
five minutes' attention
to the newspaper that conflicts of value
and differences of value are a central
and enduring feature of our society.
And if we wanna have a flourishing society
we somehow have to figure out
how to go on and how to function together
despite those enduring disagreements.
And the further complication, of course,
is that any decision about
how we're gonna go on
is itself gonna have to
be based in some values.
But since we disagree about values
it's quite difficult
to see how we can forge
a unified basis for
structuring our disagreements
and allowing one another
to pursue and respect
the different values that we have.
- And that's really what
toleration is all about.
- [Samuel] Indeed it is.
- Learning to respect
the values of others.
- Yes, toleration is itself a rich concept
and it's sometimes understood
exclusively as it were
as a kind of remedial value.
We've got two warring sects
and after a few hundred
years of doing battle
and killing each other
they finally decide that
it's just too costly
and they might as well live and let live.
And sort of better to get
along and to stop shooting
than to keep fighting forever.
And so we tolerate one another
in a thin or a minimal sense
just when we decide not to fight.
But toleration can also be
understood as a richer value,
a value which sees some affirmative worth
to constructing a society on the basis
that we're going to actually accommodate
and encourage people to
lead lives in accordance
with the values and norms
that seem authoritative
to them so far as it's possible
to accommodate them all jointly
and that it's actually a
good way of living together
and not just a way of catching our breaths
in between battles.
- It's interesting because I was reading
in this morning's paper
about the Koran burning
in Afghanistan, and that is a case where
two different peoples
are coming at each other
with different traditions
and find it very difficult
to comprehend the values of the other.
And there seems to be
no organizing structure
to create the kind of
tolerance we're talking about
as you might have in a place
like the United States itself.
- Right, and certainly
the context of a war
a war involving countries and groups
from very different religious and national
and cultural backgrounds is
not a very promising breeding
ground for breeding
structures of toleration,
which generally take a
very long time to emerge
and are somewhat precarious even under
the best of circumstances.
But it's also interesting
in those kind of cases
those kind of cases,
unfortunate as they are,
remind us how important
values are in people's lives.
You might think that what
people would get most
inflamed about were
conflicts over territory
or resources or something.
But the things that really seem to provoke
the greatest fury and be
the hardest to control
or to manage or to get beyond
are things that outrage the values
and sensibilities that
offend against things
that a particular group holds dearest.
- And interestingly enough,
in thinking about the Koran burning,
as I did after I had read your essay,
that really all the
elements come into play,
namely something is valuable
because of the tradition.
There are strong emotions.
And then people act on it in ways
that the other might feel is unreasonable
but those people feel
that it's very reasonable.
- Sure.
And people who commit
outrages like Koran burning
give tacit testimony or recognition
to the importance of values
because they know that the way
to really insult and
offend and outrage someone
is to attack what they value most deeply.
And so they don't just thwart
a significant desire that people have,
they attack the things that
really matter to people.
- I read two of your essays,
one on immigration and one on terrorism.
It really struck me when
I put them in the context
of your lectures and this
discussion of valuing
that both were at heart really about that,
different context, so that for you
in this essay immigration really is about
learning to adjust what you value,
give it a new context.
And here we're talking
about national identity
and the identity of the immigrant.
Talk a little about that
because it's coming to terms with that,
which is very important politically
in the discussions that we're having now.
- Yes, questions about
immigration are controversial
for many different reasons.
But one of the reasons
they are controversial
is that depending on the
particular kind of immigration
that we're talking about
where people are coming from
and where they're heading,
they often appear to involve
bringing into close proximity
people who previously
weren't in close proximity
and who have very different traditions,
values, attitudes, customs,
ways of life, and so on.
And they do that under circumstances
where there's a lot of
often economic pressure.
And so the stakes are
high, tensions are raised,
and what looks to be
happening is that you get a
conflict between different cultures,
the culture of the host county,
the culture of the
immigrant groups and so on.
And those kinds of conflicts can
be very difficult and
dangerous to negotiate.
One of the aims in the
essay that you referred to
was to enter a dissenting
note about the way
in which these issues
are sometimes framed.
This is a case in which,
to go back to the issue you
raised at the very beginning,
it seemed to me that some of the ways
in which the discourse about immigration
and conflicts about
immigration have been framed
have not been especially helpful.
- And in a way it's the
interest groups on both sides,
that is the people in the homeland
and then the people who have come here.
They fix on aspects of the problem
that really intensify the conflict.
So for example you have in that essay
a very interesting discussion
of the multiple identities
of a Jewish person from Eastern Europe
who came to the United States
and really his identity
is much more complex
as a result of who he was
back in his home country,
what he becomes as a
result of immigrating,
and what he becomes as
a result of settling
in the United States.
- Yeah, one of the things
that seems to me misleading
about a lot of the
discourse about immigration
on all on all sides of the issue,
is that people frame it as a conflict
between the culture of the immigrants
and the culture of the host society
in a way that suggests that
everybody has a culture.
You've got your culture,
I've got my culture.
And then if I migrate from
my country to your country
we've got a problem
because I've got my culture
but I'm in your county
and you've to your culture
and what are we gonna do now?
You're used to just having
your culture in your country.
And this whole way of talking and thinking
seems very natural.
But it overlooks the fact that culture
is a kind of protean notion.
People belong to many different groups
and have many different
kinds of allegiances,
regional, geographic, racial,
sexual, ethnic, professional,
identifications based on
their interests and so on.
And different of these identifications
and different forms of group
affiliation are salient
for people in different contexts.
If one person is from Mississippi
and another person is from New York
and they visit their respective states,
each may feel sort of culturally alien
in the other person's state.
But if the two of them
meet in India or in Africa
they may feel like
they're cultural brothers.
And that's just a way of saying
which culture you belong to
isn't a question that always
has a unique privileged answer.
And that the recognition of that fact
is crucial to, I think,
seeing how we might solve
not only problems of
immigration or some of them,
but also other problems of
living in a diverse society.
It's important to
remember that human beings
are socially extremely sophisticated
and we lead extremely complicated lives.
We move in many different
circles and many different things
and many different kinds
of people are important
to us in different contexts.
We don't just have fixed cultures
that we acquire like a set
of luggage at a certain age
and then carry with us through life.
We're always moving
around the social world
acquiring new affiliations,
and some of them are more salient
in some contexts than in others.
- And really as you explicate
this problem in this way
when the reader sees really
the dangers of politicization
of these issues because
the political discourse
often wants to fixate on
and make block and cement, so to speak,
the one identity as opposed to the--
But really what it's all about
is learning to adjust your
values in these new contexts.
- That's exactly right.
That is the difficulty with the discourse
that I was alluding to
is that once you insist
on labeling people as belonging
to a certain culture and
that's their culture,
then it locks them and
you into certain fixed
sorts of relationships.
Whereas it's essential to being
a member of a free society
that one of the things you do is that you
acquire new identifications,
and some you deepen and
some you perhaps shed
as you go through life.
In circumstances of immigration
where people are uprooted from one place
and put down in another place
it's gonna have effects on everybody.
Nobody's culture is
gonna remain unchanged.
It's a new experience for
the person who's migrating
and it's a new experience for the person
in the host society that
receives the migrant.
Each now is going to have to come to terms
with a new situation.
And that doesn't mean on the one hand
that either side has to completely abandon
all of its previous
values, customs, and so on.
That's preposterous.
On the other hand, it does mean
that each of them is gonna
have to make some adjustments.
And no sensible solution
to problems of immigration
can proceed on the basis which
denies those fairly obvious
and banal observations.
And yet a lot of the discourse
would suggest otherwise.
It would suggest that what we
have is some group of others
who come with their culture
and we've got our culture,
as if we were all the same
and belong to the same culture suddenly.
Never mind that before the immigrants came
we were locked in a culture
war within our own country.
So there's a vast oversimplification,
and its effects are almost
exclusively pernicious.
- Another essay that I read,
and again, what I'm trying to
do is just walk the audience
through just a few of the essays
of the many publications that you have
in order to reveal your way of thinking
and a philosopher's way of thinking.
And I was interested in
your article on terrorism
because really in the end
that was identifying a goal
of terrorists that in
essence is about undermining
and destabilizing what we value basically.
So in a way it's the same kind of problem.
So what are terrorists up to
and what are the implications
of that for society
and the social support for what we value?
- Well, this is another case in which
the framing discourse, it seems to me,
oversimplifies the issues in ways
that obscure rather than
illuminate what's at stake.
The very definition of
terrorism is itself now
a politically contested issue.
Some people, the governments and states
that are subject to
attack by insurgent groups
of one kind or another often
want to define terrorism
in such a way that it
applies to those groups
and only those groups
and others like them.
On the other hand,
advocates for those groups
sometimes wanna say
that no, the terrorists
are the governments that
they're fighting against.
And so pretty soon the term "terrorism"
just becomes a political football
and we lose any sense of what might
be distinctive about terrorism.
It struck me that when people
respond with horror and
outrage to terrorism
or to what they call terrorism
there is a certain kind
of central class of cases
at any rate at which something,
there is something morally
distinctive going on
that so-called terrorist
activity is different
from other forms of even
quite horrible violence.
Terrorist acts have
something special about them,
at least certain kinds of terrorist acts.
So without trying to
enter into the questions
of what the best way
to define terrorism is
or to decide who
ultimately terrorists are,
I wanted to try to unearth this phenomenon
that we often, if not
uniformly, label with the term.
And what seemed to me to be peculiar
to at least this class of
cases of terrorist activity
was that they tend to involve the use
of violence against civilians
with the aim of causing fear
in lots of other people.
The secondary targets, if you like.
The primary targets might be
the victims of the violence,
the bomb attack or the
shooting or whatever it is.
The secondary victims are
all the rest of the people
in the surrounding society
who become frightened
or alarmed by the terrorism.
And a further aim of the terrorist is
that that fear should itself serve
to destabilize or to erode
the stability or security
of the society itself in
ways that will make it harder
for people to live the
lives that they wanna lead,
to erode their capacity
to lead valuable lives
or to pursue the things that they value
in a secure situation.
So there's this moral cascade
in these kinds of cases, which
I call the standard cases.
The terrorist uses violence
against one set of people
to create fear in another set of people
with the aim of eroding or destabilizing
the structures of society more broadly.
- Two things about this essay,
well, three things struck me.
One is the clarity of laying
out this very controversial
problem which had been,
discourse had really been
corrupted by the way the
Bush administration tried
to frame the issues.
But one was the reference to Thomas Hobbes
and the philosophical tradition.
And you quote from him about the eroding
destabilizing effect of fear.
And I had forgotten the Leviathan
and it really was an amazing-
So this is a case where
going back to the philosophy
discipline and its leading
writers from the past
really explicates the problem.
- That's right.
Hobbes was, of all the great
writers of the tradition,
he's the one who most clearly emphasized
the potentially destabilizing
character of fear
and its capacity to unravel
an individual's personality
and to unravel the social order.
And in a way, Hobbes made
the desire to avoid fear
central to his whole political philosophy.
And it seemed to me that in that sense,
terrorists of the kind I'm talking about,
at any rate, are Hobbesians.
That is to say, they, too,
appreciate the power of fear
and they try to turn
it to their advantage.
Incidentally, it's not only
terrorists who do that.
Totalitarian governments also try
to exploit the power of fear.
But they have, in a way, the
opposite purpose in mind.
They wanna stabilize a kind
of corrupted social order.
They want people to be afraid
so that they won't step out of line.
And so fear is a very
potent political weapon.
And it's used in different ways,
both to destabilize certain
kinds of social orders
and to try to stabilize them.
- And that was my other point,
which is that from the essay
emerges a very clear
picture of the difference
between terrorism and state terrorism.
And in the public discourse
these terms are used very loosely.
So one side says to the other,
oh, no, the state is using terrorism
and the state of course,
but this sort of clarifies
what the differences are.
One is trying to undermine the order,
whereas the state is trying
to preserve the order.
- Yeah, that's right, with
one small qualification.
I don't want to deny that states, too,
can engage in terrorism in my sense.
They may foment terrorist
activity in other countries,
for example, particularly cynical
and machiavellian government
might actually sponsor
terrorism in its own society
as a way of inviting, in a way of creating
a demand for them to crack down.
But the distinction I drew was between
what I call terrorism and state terror
as a different phenomenon.
The phenomenon of using fear,
which states can also do,
to try to stabilize the
order that they control.
- Let's talk briefly about
your Tanner lectures.
It's a very provocative, insightful
cut into the problem of valuing actually.
What in your lectures do you
mean by the afterlife, please?
- Well, the title of the
lectures is The Afterlife.
But that's, of course, a bit of a tease.
Because I'm not really
talking about the afterlife
as people traditionally think of it.
I'm not talking about the idea
that you or I might survive
our own deaths in some form.
That idea's, of course,
central to many religious
and philosophical traditions.
But I was interested in a different idea
and I chose the term "afterlife"
partly just to be provocative
but partly also to try to explore
the relative significance to us
of the traditional notion of the afterlife
and this other idea of mine.
The idea of the afterlife
I was concerned with
is the idea that other people
will live on after I die.
So even if I don't
believe that I personally
am going to heaven after life,
I do normally take it for granted
that other people are
gonna live on after I die.
I rarely reflect seriously about it.
It's not something that it occurs to me
to question very often.
I just, of course, take it for granted
that others will live on.
The lecture, however,
the lectures that I've
been giving this week
invite us to reflect a little bit
on the significance of
this assumption we make
that other people will
live on after we die,
but that there will be what I call
a collective afterlife in that sense.
Because I believe that it's
actually quite important to us
surprisingly perhaps, it
plays a very significant role
in our lives even though
we don't recognize it
or reflect about it very often.
That if we didn't think
anyone was gonna live on
after we lived it would have great effects
on how we live now, and in particular,
it would make us lose confidence
in the value of many of the activities
whose value we now take for granted.
So in some sense, it's
extremely important to us
that life should go
on, the lives of others
should go on after we die
if we are to lead lives of value now.
Or at any rate, that's
the aim of the lecture
is to try to persuade
the audience of that.
- And what I found fascinating is
the lectures, in addition
to offering insight
about the basis for what we value,
is also indicative of a line of inquiry
in philosophical thinking.
So that in posing this
counter-factual hopefully,
is it counter-factual?
- For now.
- One, you really promote thinking
about the broader context
of which we value things.
- That's right.
I must say that one of the
central counter-factuals
that I organized the lectures around
is not original to me.
It was taken from this
wonderful novel by P.D. James
called "Children of Men."
Some people might've read
the novel or seen the film
that was made in 2006 based on the novel,
though it's rather
different from the novel.
But James asks us to imagine a world
in which human beings
suddenly become infertile
or by the time the novel begins
they've been infertile for 25 years.
So the thought is,
although without giving any plot spoilers
I won't say more, but eventually
things change in the novel.
But the expectation at
the beginning of the novel
is people are gonna die out.
There are no new people being born.
None have been born in 25 years.
And the question is how
does that affect people now?
And although she doesn't
put it in quite this way
her speculation seemed to be
that it had a demoralizing
effect on people.
That people just found it difficult
to be enthusiastic about
doing many of the things
that they've previously
valued most deeply.
Many of the activities that seemed to them
most important, most worthwhile
now seemed somehow pointless,
so they just lost confidence
in the value of pursuing them.
And that seemed to me an
extremely striking idea.
And I wanted to pursue it a little further
and to try to think about, first of all,
how far reaching those effects might be.
And second of all, what does that say
about us and our values?
Isn't it an interesting
fact, if it is a fact,
that we would lose confidence in the value
of things we're now doing in our lives
if we thought that they weren't going
to be any people in the future?
One thing that's interesting about that,
a couple of things are
quite striking about it.
One is that we don't
seem to lose confidence
in the value of our
activities just because
we know that we're gonna die.
People know that they're gonna die
but they mind dying
partly because they have
so many things that they value doing
and they wanna keep doing them.
They don't think, gee, I'm
gonna die so nothing matters.
They think, oh, how terrible
it is I'm gonna die,
among other reasons, because
there are all these things
that matter to me that
I'd like to be able to do
or to see through to completion or so on.
So it's interesting to think
that the prospect that
human beings might die out
even after one died oneself,
could have a demoralizing
effect on one's capacity
to pursue one's values in this life.
The other thing that's
interesting about this is
that these effects are produced on us
not because of our personal attachment
to any of these as yet unborn people.
They're unborn.
We don't know who they are.
They have no identities.
And yet the fact that they
might not come into existence
seems to have a more profound effect on us
and our values than does the fact that we
ourselves are gonna die or even the people
we care most deeply about, the
fact that they're gonna die.
None of those things seem to prevent us
from maintaining our
confidence in the value
of the activities that
seem valuable to us.
But the thought that
unborn people in the future
might never come into existence,
that would strike us as
devastating and catastrophic.
That seemed to me quite
an interesting insight.
- And it's fascinating because
generally we think about,
if we're addressing the
problem of climate change,
for example, we say, oh, we wanna
the future generations
are dependent on us,
and therefore we wanna do
something about climate change.
But the insight that you discover
is that in a way we are dependent on them,
which is the reverse of
what we normally think.
- That's right.
The prevailing discourse
certainly within philosophy,
but I think also in the wider culture
when it comes to thinking
about future generations
and the effects on future
generations of our behavior now,
whether it's with
respect to global warming
or having other destructive
effects on the environment
the prevailing discourse
is to think roughly
there's this class of people
who are gonna exist in the future.
They have no power to
speak for themselves,
but they're very vulnerable to us.
If we do stuff, we're gonna
make their lives miserable.
We really ought to pay more
attention to that fact,
that somehow we have an
obligation to protect
this vulnerable class of people,
the as yet nonexistent
people who will come
into existence in the future.
And that makes it seem as if
this is a moral burden on us.
It's something we should do, as it were,
one more set of moral obligations.
And it's sort of kind of like
we've got to eat our spinach and do right
by future generations,
which doesn't seem very
successful, by the way,
in motivating most
people most of the time.
But it seemed to me that
that discourse really
obscured in some ways
the most salient feature
of our relations to future generations.
Of course, they are dependent on us
in certain obvious ways,
causally dependent.
If we pollute the water,
they'll have to deal with it.
If we make the environment toxic,
that will have terrible effects on them.
But a relation at least as important
or more important that runs
in the opposite direction.
If they don't exist,
then what we're doing now
doesn't seem worthwhile.
And so in a way we depend on them.
And that's a very different kind of reason
for wanting to protect
them and their interests.
Our capacity now to lead lives
that we see as valuable
depends on our confidence
that there will be people in the future.
And so if we act in ways
that give us reason to
lose that confidence,
then among other things
we're undermining our own ability to lead
valuable lives now.
- Now superficially one might think
that what I value is related
to my property, for example,
and so therefore it's
a very individualistic,
egoistic kind of thing.
But you're saying really
that what we value
really depends around not
only the people around us
but the people in the future.
And so at the base of
valuing is recognizing
that what we value is
part of an ongoing history
which then allows us to value that thing.
So it's not selfish and egoistic in a way.
- Well, I think in a
way that this is a place
where the language of egoism and altruism
doesn't help us very much.
It's one of those dichotomies that tends
to oversimplify a complex reality.
In terms of the content
of their current values,
people differ considerably.
Some people have values that are
in one recognizable
sense sort of egoistic.
They're focused on themselves
and their own satisfactions
and gratification.
Other people have values that are
in the similar sense more social
or they're more oriented toward
helping people or helping society.
So human beings vary in these respects.
But what's interesting is that
what I take what I call
the afterlife conjecture
to suggest the fact that people would lose
confidence in their values
under those circumstances
to suggest that even people whose values
strike us as in one sense fairly egoistic
would suddenly find if they thought
that human beings were about to die out,
that a lot of stuff that seemed to them
obviously worth doing no
longer seemed as worth doing.
Would you really want to
build a real estate empire
as people were gradually fading out?
(chuckle)
Would venture capitalists, entrepreneurs,
would they continue to feel as motivated
to do what they were doing
if they thought that human life were going
to about to come to an end, for example?
So there are lots of different kinds
of projects and activities that seem to me
to be threatened in the sense
that they would no longer
seem to make as much sense.
I discuss everything
from a scientist trying
to cure cancer, people trying to work
to improve seismic safety in the Bay area,
to creative artists or novelists
who are writing, to the
work of philosophers.
Would I really feel
motivated to get up and write
my next article if I
thought that human beings
were about to disappear from the planet?
Not at all clear that I would.
So that it's not just altruists
in one sense of the term,
but people across a broad array of values
who suddenly find that the things
that mattered most to
them no longer seemed
quite as significant.
And that suggests that even though
some of us are more and
some of us are less egoistic
in one sense, we're all
rather less egoistic
than we might have
thought in another sense;
namely that we're much more dependent on
and vulnerable to
catastrophe befalling others
or befalling humanity as a whole
than we are even to
our own personal debts.
Because again, none of
the people in question
would lose confidence in the value
of what they're doing
just because they know
that their mortal.
We all know that we're mortal,
but we think it's important
to do what we're doing.
But if we thought that the human race
were about to die out,
then even the egoists among us might find
that they no longer saw much point
in what they were doing.
And to the extent that that's true,
it suggests that they, too,
are more vulnerable
and dependent on others
than we might have thought.
And one thing I take away from that
is that the language
of egoism and altruism
doesn't describe very well the nature
of the ways that human beings
are intertwined with one another.
- One final question,
and that relates to students
who might be watching the program.
Do you have any suggestions or advice
about how they should
prepare for the future
if they wanna follow a similar
or a comparable intellectual journey
and engage in philosophical inquiring?
- Well, I don't think that
I have any very original
or novel advice.
It think for someone
who's entering the subject
the best thing to do is simply to follow
the time-honored path of trying
to learn about the
philosophical tradition,
to study its great works,
to familiarize oneself
with the habits of thought
and to try to enter into
those habits of thought
as best one can with an
eye toward eventually
being able to pursue the
philosophical questions
that matter most to one.
The one thing I would say
and any philosopher would say this
is that philosophical education
can't be just passive.
The description I just gave
might've made it sound that way.
Go read the great philosophers,
study the great works.
But from the earliest phase
of philosophical study,
philosophical education has to be active.
You have to be reading these
things and learning about them,
but part of the way you learn about them
is by thinking about them,
by talking about them with other people,
by trying yourself to address
the philosophical questions
to use your own intellectual resources
as best you can to try to work out
what you think about certain questions.
And of course over time your answers
will become more
sophisticated and refined.
It's not that on your first day
you're gonna produce a
publishable piece of work,
but rather, that really
the way to appreciate
philosophical issues and their complexity
is not only to read what
others have said about them
or to familiarize yourself
with the tradition,
but it's also a matter of yourself trying
to work it out so that
you run into the dead ends
and you see the difficulties that have led
the great philosophers to go this way
rather than that way
or you see how the choice points
that have divided great philosophers
loom up and why people have
divided over certain issues.
That's really crucial
to eventually becoming
an independent philosopher yourself.
- Well, on that note,
Sam, thank you very much
for coming back to Berkeley,
delivering the Tanner lectures,
and being a guest on our program.
This was a very insightful
and revealing interview, thank you.
- Thank you very much,
Harry, it's been a pleasure.
- And thank you very much for joining us
for this Conversation with History.
(upbeat music)